kristina is on the line in nashville hi
Kristina how are you I'm doing pretty
good thanks for taking my call babe sure
what's up
okay so he's got a huge mess going on
with my 19 year old sister she's got two
kids both of them wanted just turned one
the other one just turned two six weeks
ago her 12 month old was diagnosed with
stage 3 cancer hmm and two weeks before
that happened she was on her way to work
and a kamikaze driver pulled out in
front of her on the highway and she told
her vehicle she was upside down I guess
yeah upside down on the loan which I had
advised against in the first place on
that car and so insurance didn't cover
all of that so there's still money owed
on that and then like it's a two weeks
later her 12 month old was diagnosed
with cancer and my husband and I we've
been helping out as much as we can
really the last couple of months but she
did not listen when it came to getting a
new car and she went to one of those
blind painter Lots before the diagnosis
and you know she's had to miss a lot of
work traveling back and forth with
chemotherapy and as of last night the
car got repoed hasn't even been six
weeks trying to figure out how to help
her I don't want to send her any more
money to be honest with you she's not
making good choices with that with
regards to the car trying to figure out
I mean should she get should she get to
call it back I think she should just let
it go and you know ride the bus but then
my mom told me that she's not really
feasible I'm really just not a loss at
this point watch what your mom what's
your mom gonna do yeah this is not
feasible it's not feet your mom is
saying it's not feasible so you should
give her money I mean that's one need
opinion no no I
my mom is incapable of giving any money
to my sister she's yeah you know so
she's got a lot of opinion so she's got
a lot of opinions about other people's
money is my point okay so my point is I
don't care what your mom says now the I
mean you got a lot of broke people that
got opinions about money around you yeah
yeah I I feel like I didn't move far
enough away no I mean you can still love
your family I'm not suggesting that but
I've got two rules one is I don't argue
with broke people about money because
they're wrong okay
like I don't argue about fat people
about diets you know I'm just obviously
they're wrong I mean you wouldn't argue
with me about growing hair I'm not real
good at it so I've been wrong right so I
mean you know that kind of stuff so you
just you know all of that now the so how
can you help without falling in and
being part of the craziness I think you
put your sister in a big bear hug and
you say listen sis I love you
you and you're in a heartbreaking
situation right here and you keep making
some really dumb butt choices you're
acting like a dumb butt you really are I
love you but you're my dumb butt but
you're dumb I mean you're doing some
dumb stuff and you just holding it we're
just hugging her neck the whole time
you're talking to her right and here's
here's the thing I want to help you but
people who won't take my financial
advice I don't give money to no matter
how much I love them no matter how much
I love them or how sad their situation
is if they won't take my advice I won't
give them money that's rule number one
and then rule number two is uh you know
you're gonna have to start making some
better decisions I'll walk with you I'll
coach you I got your back I'm here but
I'm not going to support you misbehaving
because it's not good for you it doesn't
affect me it just aggravates me but it
destroys your life I mean you made two
stupid car decisions and it sounds like
she's making some other decisions that
are in question with babies popping out
everywhere here am I wrong yeah you're
right right there all right and so I
mean this kids going she just keeps my
decisions making her life hard so is
where's the baby where's the chemo she
she lives in South Indiana the chemos up
in Indianapolis so they have to travel
once a week you know three and a half
hours and that's all paid for
I believe that Medicaid will supply a
ride if she needs it baby is all the
babies being paid taken care of is what
I'm concerned about yes yes Medicaid
covering that okay because st. Jude is
there too you know you don't pay a dime
at st. Jude so you can check them out as
well that's Memphis of course now now so
here's the thing yes I would get her a
car I get her a thousand dollar car but
it's under my term it's under my terms
and my terms are that you're gonna while
you're in that car you're gonna be
listening to these CDs and you're going
to learn about handling money and you're
gonna get your little butt in church and
you're gonna start straightening up your
life right and if you don't want to do
that I can't help you because if you're
gonna be crazy I'm not gonna finance
you're crazy right I'm not I'm gonna
drunk a drink and if you're doing heroin
I'm not buying your heroin and if you're
misbehaving with money I'm not gonna
fund more money mistakes because I love
you that's your that's your Treacher
speech to her okay right trying to grow
up well you know for all of us I mean
you can be 52 and making stupid
decisions right but this one's this one
she's just she's laying out stuff here
that's gonna cause her to have long
decades out in front of her and so I
want her to do better and I listen if
she'll go through the class or while
she's while the kids in chemo sit and
watch the DVDs or something I'll give it
to her but and you can make that part of
the deal if you want you need to go
through this class and I want to give it
to you and it's not that we're trying to
control her life it's that we're trying
to help her make better decisions
because if she keeps making the kind of
decisions she's been making her life's
gonna continue to get worse so this is
like that's called love it's called love
not participating in people
you love's insanity is loving them well
does that make sense yes so hold on I'll
have Kelly pick up and we'll give you a
home study course for Financial Peace
University so while she's sitting there
while the kids in chemo she can sit and
watch these DVDs all right and I'll be
her coach on the financial side if can
you scrape together a thousand dollars
to get her little car I think I think I
can probably do that yes if you can and
you want to then then that but I
wouldn't do it unless she's going to go
along with starting to make some good
decisions and and and you know the first
step of making good decisions is saying
the other ones were bad that's called
the spiritual term for that's repentance
looking and saying I was stupid over
there I'm no longer gonna be stupid
that's repentance and I've been stupid
so I've repented from it I know what it
looks like so I'm not picking on her
I've been 19 and stupid too so the
question is where's she gonna be when
she's 29
it ain't looking good unless she changes
her direction hold on I'll have Kelly
pick up this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
and so you have to break the cycle you
have to flip this thing on its head and
make it behave you've got to get so
fired up and wired up that you're broke
friends think you've lost your mind
you